Tuyên bộ mừng nhất của tổng thống đơn đơn trâm về khả năng áp hội thủ cấp lên hàng hoang hả,
và các cú gia sáo thương với Más Căva đang gây sáo chổn chung cục diện ngoại giao khu bực.
Theo dưới phần tiết, chính xác này cũng chỉ nhằm siết chạm Más Căva mà còn đặt áp lực lên,
các nước nhập khẩu dầu mỏng hả như Trung Quốc bán đổ.
Hay đối tác của vị thế ngày gàn quan trọng trong chiến lực đối ngoại của Washington.
Ừ, đổ, bốn tăng mạnh nhập khẩu dầu từng áp vào năng hành ím không trọng hề mẹi.
Đăng tổ ra thật chung, Trung Quốc cơ biển hưởng chức kép.
Trung kiếm đỏ Trung Quốc ở đa bức tiến Trung thương mại cộng nghệ với vị,
lại đối mặt với vị cơ bị kéo vào căng thống mới.
Các chuyên xác châu dành, Thuy thương cấp có thể phạm tác sộn.
Anh hưởng để tiến trình đả phán và quan để xong phương bốn mong măng.
Ngay cả trong lội bộ mi, không ý địa kiến tổ ra hoang íb,
bây hiệu khoa của chính xác thủy này, châu dành nó khó khả thị và dễ gây ta đồng hưởng.
Trong bộ cảnh của mình đăng cùng của anh hưởng.
Nhưng nộn hơi như vậy có thể đẩy các khu ra châu á,
xích lại gần nhau hơn.
Sa dự quý đào anh hưởng của mình.